en 30 ans le VIH aura fait plus de 32
millions de morts c'est presque deux
fois plus que toutes les victimes de la
Première Guerre mondiale dans le loup
trois personnes ont réussi en guérir
c'est peu alors comment elles ont fait
pourquoi c'est aussi dur de trouver un
remède à ton seul mot une petite piste
pour un jour espérer guérir l'humanité
vous allez voir c'est pas gagné avoir le
VIH est plus compliqué que vous ne le
pensez si vous prenez une foule de 500
personnes en France statistiquement une
sera séropositive elle fera même
peut-être partie des 24000 qui vivent
avec cette maladie sans le savoir et si
c'était vous le cas échéant vous
n'auriez vraiment pas eu de chance parce
que statistiquement c'est pas si facile
à attraper vous avez peur de vous
baigner dans la même piscine qu'un
séropositif 0% de chance utiliser la
même seringue que lui
0,8% oui c'est peu pareil pour les
rapports sexuels la contamination est
loin d'être systématique il y a
plusieurs études qui ont été faites et
vous voyez selon les pratiques les
chances d'être contaminés changent
beaucoup 0,1%
le VIH va fusionner avec sa membrane et
il pondre son ARN à l'intérieur c'est
comme alien le bébé VIH va manger vos
nutriments et utiliser votre machine riz
cellulaire pour se reproduire tout ça
dans le but de se répliquer encore et
encore des milliers de milliards de
virus sont produits chaque jour à la
chaîne la cellule est vidée de sa
substance elle gonfle s'enflamme et
explose comme une grenade à
fragmentation des milliers de débris
chimiques sont projetés faisant alors
tour exploser d'autres lymphocytes c'est
moins le VIH qu'il estime que votre
corps qui se défend c'est pour ça
qu'après l'infection vous aurez des
petits symptômes un peu de fièvre des
ganglions flammés des maux de gorge un
rhume quoi en réalité vous êtes en face
de primo-infection et ça passe en
quelques jours qui penserait au VIH
d'autant plus qu'un test standard en
labo ne détectera rien avant 6 semaines
après la contamination la raison c'est
qu'à ce stade votre corps lutte plutôt
bien contre le VIH il lui démonte la
figure et ça peut durer comme ça des
années
on s'en rende compte vous vivez sans
symptômes du moins pendant 10 ans si
vous avez de la chance le problème c'est
que votre corps s'épuise finit par ne
plus faire le poids contre cette
présence constante démarre alors la
deuxième étape quelque chose cloche une
fièvre qui ne passe pas diarrhée
infection de la peau mycose rien de
grave mais ça fait plein de petites
maladies qui mettent la puce à l'oreille
au médecin va donc vous faire un test le
test ne détectera pas directement le
virus ça serait trop long à la place on
va détecter les anticorps qui luttent
contre le VIH résultat vous vous êtes
séropositif sans traitement vous passez
alors à la dernière phase le sida le
test révélateur c'est l'état de vos
lymphocytes ce qui éclatent à la chaîne
normalement c'est 20% de vos globules
blancs mais si les taux sont trop bas
c'est mauvais signe sans traitement il
vous reste moins de 3 ans à vivre le VIH
a détruit quasi toutes vos défenses
immunitaires et votre corps ne peut plus
défendre il suffira d'une petite grippe
d'une petite bactérie dans un aliment et
vous en mourrez les cancers peuvent se
dém sans que rien ne les arrête en
réalité on ne meurt pas du sida mais des
maladies qui laissent émerger en vous ça
fait peur alors vous vous posez sûrement
la question existe-t-il des traitements
contre le VIH oui le premier est un
traitement post-infection le TPE
efficace à 80 % cyprès 4h après
l'exposition au bout de 48 heures c'est
déjà trop tard son but bloqué la
reproduction du virus par tous les
moyens on va l'empêcher de s'attacher à
la cellule de fusionner avec elle
d'injecter son ARN et d'utiliser votre
machinerie interne il est complètement
paralysé détruit depuis l'extérieur mais
il faut faire vite si vous le prenez
trop tard et que le virus a eu le temps
de s'installer il existe une deuxième
solution la trithérapie de stabilisation
pourquoi le TPE ne marche plus pourquoi
ça ne les radique plutôt totalement
parce que le virus a eu le temps de se
cacher dans les ganglions le lieu de
stockage de vos défenses immunitaires et
là-bas la trithérapie ne marche pas
parce que le virus s'y met en dormance
il ne se multiplie pas il chill en
attendant de pouvoir se réveiller le
fait et qu'en prenant vos trois pilules
tous les jours sang et clean il y a
quasiment plus de VIH qui se balade
parce que dès qu'un virus tente sa
chance il est éliminé vous n'êtes plus
contaminant c'est comme si vous étiez
guéri mais pas totalement parce que
quelque part Terry au fond de votre
corps il attend que la voix se libère
pour se réveiller est-ce que c'est cool
pas tant que ça la trithérapie a des
effets secondaires augmentation du
risque d'infractus trouble de la
répartition de la Grèce atteinte du foie
des reins et même des os aujourd'hui une
personne qui a le VIH à la même
expérience de vie qu'une personne sent
mais dans quelles conditions sans
compter que le VIH a un grand pouvoir de
mutation un traitement bien équilibré
depuis des années peut ne plus
fonctionner du jour au lendemain c'est
vraiment le roi des virus il a tout
compris pour survivre au maximum ce qui
le rend invincible sauf pour trois
personnes qui ont réussi à totalement le
supprimer de leur corps comment ont-ils
faites-vous partie des gens immunisés au
VIH oui il existe trois cas de rémission
complète les patients de Berlin de
Londres et récemment de New York mais le
miracle n'a été possible qu'en trichant
car en plus du VIH ces trois malades
avaient une une maladie du sang mortel
la chance quoi la solution c'est une
grève de moelle osseuse la substance qui
produit vos globules rouges et vos
globules blancs justement ce que le VIH
infecte il se trouve qu'avec la leucémie
la moelle est défectueuse et il faut la
changer l'idée d'en récupérer sur un
donneur sain retirer la moelle du malade
et lui injecter la nouvelle coup de
chance pour nos trois miraculés les
donneurs faisaient partie des 1% de la
population dotée d'une résistance
naturelle contre le VIH oui ça existe
elles sont porteuses d'une mutation rare
à rappeler CCR-5 Delta 32 qui empêche au
virus de s'accrocher à la cellule
malheureusement c'est impossible
d'utiliser la greffe comme traitement ça
demande d'avoir 100000 dollars sur son
compte un donneur compatible avec toi et
qui a la résistance au virus de subir
une chimiote ou furieux plusieurs mois
d'hospitalisation éventuellement un
petit coma et 30% de chance de mourir
pendant l'opération il y a d'autres
personnes dans le monde qui sans avoir
une résistance complète arrive à
tellement limiter le virus qu'il n'est
quasiment plus détectable dans le sang
comme avec une le crithérapie on les
appelle les contrôleurs élites c'est
très rare 0,5% des contaminés mais
comment font-ils on sait toujours pas
c'est une énorme piste pour un
traitement si on arrivait à reproduire
ce super pouvoir chez d'autres patients
le VIH deviendrait un virus inoffensif
pour l'homme il existe aussi des gens
qui développent cette capacité après une
trithérapie les contrôleurs
post-traitement ils arrêtent leur
médicament mais continue d'en avoir les
effets c'est entre 5 et 15% des infectés
plus vous prendrez tôt la trithérapie
plus vous avez de chances d'en faire
partie là encore on a toujours aucune
idée du pourquoi pourquoi n'y a-t-il pas
de vaccins obéh 40 ans que le virus est
connu est toujours rien la covid ça a
été réglé en moins de 12 mois pourquoi
une telle différence en fait il existe
des vaccins contre le VIH mais leur taux
d'efficacité est assez faible cette
année un vaccin par ARN messager est en
phase de test et c'est très prometteur
le problème c'est que le virus infecte
directement les cellules en charge de
vous protéger or le principe d'un vaccin
c'est d'entraîner cellules à réagir
contre un attaquant le vaccin t'apprend
à boxer le VIH te coupe le bras mais on
peut encore utiliser ses pieds on est
capable de produire des anticorps contre
le VIH le problème c'est qu'il se cache
alors comment identifier les cellules
infectées en dormance elles sont
identiques aux autres ni les médicaments
au niveau défenses immunitaires ne
peuvent voir à travers vos cellules on a
néanmoins inventé quelque chose qui
ressemble à un vaccin la prep vous
n'êtes pas infecté vous voulez un
rapport sans préservatif avec votre
partenaire qui a le virus avec la prep
ce n'est pas un problème ce médicament
va agir comme un comité d'accueil le VIH
entre toi mais va se faire bolosser avec
impossibilité pour lui de se reproduire
la prise reste contraignante tous les
jours à heure fixe mais un taux
d'efficacité à 98% si on ajoute ça aux
statistiques de tout à l'heure ça limite
vraiment les risques mais ça ne guérit
pas voilà pourquoi plusieurs autres
pistes de traitement sont à l'étude par
exemple avec les thérapies géniques on
peut errant des lymphocytes T4 d'une
personne affectée résistante au virus
comme chez les contrôleurs naturels
notre piste serait le choc and kill
trouver un moyen de réveiller tous les
virus en dormance pour pouvoir tous les
laser-radiquer d'un coup grâce à une
trithérapie de choc malheureusement
cette méthode pourrait aussi réveiller
d'autres virus voire même des cancers et
il existe encore plein d'autres pistes
arrivé à identifier les virus en dormant
utilisez des enzymes pour empêcher le
virus d'entrer dans les cellules une
grève de moelle osseuse qui serait sûr
un vaccin thérapeutique ou endormir le
virus pour toujours la recherche est à
fond sur le sujet parce que ce virus est
la clé pour mieux comprendre notre
système immunitaire on pourrait presque
utiliser toutes les techniques vicieuses
de ce virus pour en faire des
médicaments à l'avenir maintenant il est
vrai que si 40 ans après on a toujours
rien c'est que pendant longtemps c'était
pas la mobilisation générale dans la
recherche parce que cette maladie touche
principalement quatre types de
communautés marginalisées les
communautés gays les utilisateurs de
drogue les non-blancs et les femmes aux
États-Unis 85 des nouvelles infections
touchant les hommes l’été lors de
rapport du même sexe 70% elle était dans
les communautés ethniques marginalisées
et on parle d'une étude où les femmes ne
sont même pas compter elles représentent
pourtant 20% des nouveaux infectés aux
États-Unis avec encore une fois une
écrase en disparité ethnique les femmes
noires étant 20 fois plus touchées que
les blanches constat assez similaire en
France malheureusement le continent
africain porte clairement la croix de
cette épidémie avec plus de 70% des
infectés à l'échelle mondiale dans
certaines régions c'est même une
personne sur trois qui est touchée dans
ces pays les chances de contamination
sont jusqu'à 10 fois plus élevés qu'en
Occident pour un même type de rapport
pourquoi on ne sait pas il a des
explications culturelles sociales mais
aussi génétiques certains gènes présents
chez les afrodescendants seraient
suspectés de favoriser la contamination
le fait est que la peur du sida a permis
de faire reculer d'autres maladies tout
aussi dangereuses et pas de site
syphilisent chlamydia herpès qui je vous
rappelle ont tué Al Capone Lénine
Maupassant Schubert des hommes au sommet
qui ont tout perdu pour une coucherie
d'un soir il y a 2000 ans la capote
existait déjà et depuis on a rien trouvé
de mieux pour se protéger de
l'intégralité de ces saletés alors
encore une fois sortez couvert et en
attendant c'est à nous de vous remercier
pour le palier des 500 000 abonnés c'est
une aventure incroyable continuer avec
toute l'équipe jusqu'au million et
promis ce jour-là on vous réservera une
petite surprise en lançant le projet
sciences trash on voulait vous
communiquer à Max de savoir et en
particulier ma passion des maths on peut
dire un grand merci à nos rédacteur et
monteur n'hésitez pas à nous suivre sur
les réseaux on vous dit à très vite à
bientôt les amis Ciao